in dem film geht es unter anderem ums
thema anorexie und sexualisierte gewalt
gebe im logo auf die acht
noch nie so
kurz gefühl aber wenn es jetzt
eigentlich jetzt groß video ist häufig
durch sich magersüchtige personen auf
social media und die forderung mit
fatalen folgen
unsere recherchen zeigen in einer vor
und schätzt um letztlich ludwig
hilflosigkeit vor der betroffene
schamlos ausnutzen sogenannte coaches
noch über 20 minuten ist auch
wenn wir was hartes wollen musste meine
sklavin sein du gehörst alleine mir bist
du die 42 kilogramm liegst ich darf mit
dir machen was ich möchte
über regler und bestrafe die anorexie
coaches massiv die die personen
[Musik]
auf den grund
ich bin der foto baumann weit klinik im
kanton aargau und ich lebe jetzt
angedacht janet die liebe zählt mehrere
jordan als störung und letscho hat sie
der diagnose anorexie büro musste
folglich mit ihrer weiß ich dass social
media in loser triebes schwerer
krankheit wenn ich jetzt mal mit ihrem
gott jeanette wird sie dieser woche
stationär behandelt insgesamt ist sie
schon siebenmal in die klinik sie auch
wenn andere psychische probleme
hier mit der feldpost
sie haben die pause zwei kolleginnen
woche und sie hat mal so ganz folgen oft
schäme mich so dass man vor der ständig
rom accessoires vor lassen ja es ist
halt so sagte mir du nord wake up
tonight will
painting to view
also etwa so aufwendig da am 27
das so denn hier ist und das lasse mir
eigentlich nochmals verinnerlicht dass
ich das alles mache
ein fixer bestandteil vom
therapieprogramm jeanette muss zweimal
pro woche oft weg
[Musik]
bist du nicht mache ich also gut aber du
nicht möchte ich zeigen wo ist
eigentlich so nicht
weitermachen
weil aber so eine zahl sagt nicht viel
aus
und darum
und welche hausmeisters zahlungslösungen
wenn das so
wie ich das ding ja da ist was auf eine
pizza
der
richter
glaubte
sidney 8
also ich weiß nach halte ich mich raus
sind eben nur als ich im sommer felix
jehle pizzeria und die pizza hat also
auf das bis heute gerne habe ich jedes
ungefähr erfreut
auf die pizza
und über das web ist willst du sagen so
war es
und so einfach ist das kindliche freude
auf das mega cool stuff
macht eigentlich
mit ihrem labor dreht sich momentan
alles um ihr die krankheit auf tecdoc
teilt sie ihre geschichte sie habe wähle
ein humorvoller umgang mit ihrer
magersucht schaffe
es geht aber auch hosszu editor und
verzweiflung ausdruck hat
es kühlt das vielleicht bald lernt wie
er was inspiration genutzt hat zum thema
geschäftsbetrieb ich denke es gibt
sicher nicht wahr gefunden hat so wenig
aufsehen aber ich habe es mir eigentlich
nie so versucht so lange auch immer so
dargestellt das ist eine komische ich
bin aber tik tok ist jeanette auch in
eine sogenannte plan az xii anna dass
ich kurz für anorexie die whatsapp
gruppen ganze essgestörte mancher
gegenseitig tipps zu wieder öffne dich
zwar nicht aber nicht nur gleichgesinnte
begegnet sondern auch mancher wo ganz
andere absichten verfolgen sogenannte
coaches was sind das für manche und was
verlangen sie vor der betroffene
zusammen mit meinen studienkollegen ein
leckerli und marisa einem studium zu dem
thema recherchiert die beide hat sich
über verdeckte
schließt und hat somit über hohe was den
ab kurz denn für eine gruppe ist einem
klub der regel weg geschickt worden
wo sachstände wie ihr dass man immer
muss es das feedback geht dass man jetzt
muss geheim halte die gruppe
bereits jetzt zum beispiel forschte
44 stunden gefastet keine lust mehr aber
label es sich regelmäßig 200 kalorien
als wieder wie früher 90 stunden zu
fasten und dann zu wünschen ich glaube
ein wichtiger punkt ist zur kirche ist
nicht allein mit seiner krankheit
verstanden möchte
endlich menschen
mangels normaler umfeld der verstand
versteigt das ist ein problem sie und
was die lizenz für die 2 es gab sehr
wichtiger punkt ist
nicht verurteilt also die schadet sicher
berger 70 gruppen immer
absolut ja es ist die personalisierung
psychisch krank und sie diese einfach
nur weiter die krankheit
während unsere recherche jets im beruf
ist phänomen gestoßen wo bislang weniger
öffentlichkeit ruhig manche wo sich
coaches mannes sie suchen kontakt zu
magersüchtige und versprachen abhilfe
als 18 jahre
ein
anderes handy und ein anderes verwandelt
dann kann man sich besser vorstellen
namen wollte größe gewicht und
wunschgewicht metern gemacht haben
unternehmen nichts mehr aktuelle
bodychecks schicken das heißt einfach
bilder
jetzt
während den bilder geschickt wo mir über
photoshop bearbeitet haben
und wenn ich krank wurde
vivendi stuhr verbucht also tragen muss
es sie und möchte unser ziel ist in zwei
manager
und mein ganzer körper kennenlernen und
minister für das extrem hart corsi noch
über 20 minuten ist auch
wenn wir was wollen musste meine sklavin
sein du gehörst alleine mir bist du die
42 kilogramm liegst ich darf mit ihm
machen was ich möchte
der begriff woche ein ich gebe jeden
abend die kalorien grenze für den
folgetag bekannt nach 20 uhr nichts mit
essen jeden morgen wegen und gewicht
mitteilen keine gezückten getränke und
bei regel produktionen strafen und
dennis burgio wirklicher schock
und in zukunft möchte ich dich nackt
sehen auf den bildern der name programm
ist das zwingend nackt ii und 1 hätte
gescheit ja
etwas begrenzt sagt rocco es gab mehrere
grenzen für innerliche dass der körper
team kehrt
damit die komplette kontrolle hat
drückt man damit wir von anderen besser
gesehen und psychologischer grund
damit
nach
festen freund oder freundin
und weckt ich dann
ja und bis zu dem zeitpunkt da die
scorecard animus mich jemand ausgang uns
nachgefragt wird reagieren wenn man
minderjährig waren also würde ich
bin nicht so wichtig sondern erst recht
aber hätten
berichten aktuell von der wandel
verlangt und was ist denn zu dem
zeitpunkt als dank das waren 15 ist und
das ist auch nicht abgefunden haben so
jetzt und dann haben uns als
journalistin arbeitet und an seiner
stelle zu
[Musik]
chatten dass sie interessant mehr an in
denen zum beispiel damit konfrontiert
und klopp wieso foto minderjährigen
warum der nacktbilder verlangt und das
ist
ja das ganze thema ist
da spielt auch keine rolle ob man ist
eine brille trägt sicher hagemann hat
oder allgemein vom gesicht
ja das muss man aber verstehen ich weiß
das ist wirklich sehr sehr fragwürdig
mindestens fragwürdig aber man hat da
wirklich kein sexuelles verlangen oder
meiner mama sexuelles auch wenn es für
außenstehende
was
mich wie ein das ganze thema aber spielt
zählt der dribbel und tut die frage
beantworten alles was nicht und das
schlimme das etwas wird es das ist
überhaupt nicht schlimm es verdient dass
ich so alltag und höre ich mache doch
nicht falsch und das stand ja meistens
dann
in der
sich bewusst ist dass er mit denen
riesige wunde
wanderweg mit der kalorien begrenzt und
ein wunsch weil sie nach der reichen das
ist zwar hat trainer in eine
lebensbedrohliche lage bringe das kann
ganz schnell gehen so steht es ist gott
sei dank aber nie ganz geworden
beschreibt lebensbedrohlich
natürlich stimmt also dass
das muss einfach hardcore
sonne hat persönlich treffen
die aussagen nicht so und prozent wenn
man mit diversen
psychologe psychologinnen geredet und
macht aus einem pauschalisieren was
motivation hin dass man kann nicht sagen
das sind alles pädophilie liegt das ist
ja genau das ist mir
dass dort jede jeder einzelnen coach ist
irgendwie ein anderes dahinter doch
nicht so dass etwas machen
am anfang für den wahrscheinlich dank
dass das mit deiner coaches einzelfall
sind aber dass das phänomen doch
verbreitet ist und dass man als
betroffene person so schnell rutschen
das schockiert mich alter sohn war super
lobte die nixe und kontakt mit coaches
ist an ich gebe es jetzt ein gerade per
video call sich seit über zwei jahren
magersüchtig und hat auch gerade ein
klinikaufenthalt in frankfurt hinter
sich
wenn sie einen knopf fortschritt gemacht
hat also wer sie nicht zu erkennen 12 20
und vorübergehend ebene betreuten
wohnheim bis sie hoffentlich in eine
andere klinik zu ihrem schutz haben wir
die anonymisiert wie hast du dein
kontakte zu den coaches aufgenommen
wieso wolltest du das
war
weniger
der einzige mann lebe ich irgendwie
schon oder empfinden kann in der ich
sehen dass ich gut bin so ich bin
das ist irgendetwas kann
was haben die dann verlangt von dir
nacktbilder
dass sie halt den kompletten körper
beurteilen können und das nicht nur
einmal sondern mehrmals
profilen den körper von vorne von hinten
gewürgt
namens seite aus allen möglichen
positionen halt und das hat nicht nur
einmal sondern teilweise halt beim
täglich oder mehrmals täglich
hast du das geschickt
leider ja aber
also nicht gerne aber ich habe mich
schon auch irgendwie so unter druck
gesetzt gefühlt und habe auch schon
immer scheiße aussehen zu finden so dass
ich das so wenn etwas nackt machen muss
sondern halt in unterwäsche mir hat was
du da
eigentlich so schlecht ich war unser
herz wenn ich glaube schon gesteuert von
krankheit
dass die schule gegangen was ich vorher
sehr gern bin habe ich alleine
weil einfach generell unglücklich
beschäftigt sich das heute noch ja also
die betreuung solcher menschen überhaupt
gibt
kranke kinder psychisch
krank ist eure ausbildung
kannst du diese gut auf irgendeine art
raum geben
ich weiß nicht glaube ich meine gefühle
zu trauer oder sonst irgendwas
machen fordert glaube ich immer meine
störung
muss
selbst die entscheidungen quasi direkt
ob ich wirklich leben will und
das bedeutet irgend gegen diese
krankheit anzukämpfen
egal wie schwer es wird oder ob wirklich
komplett aufnehme und mich
krankheit quasi ergebe diese
entscheidung habe ich einfach noch nicht
getroffen weil sein dass das erschienene
entscheidung und ich lieben mich halt in
dieser ambivalenz die geistige und rote
briefe was da genau passiert ist aber
ich sehe was es bis heute mit ihrer
macht
er schmeckte aber
ich bin so hastig wenn du hast ruft die
coaches wo so sehr auf verfügbarkeit wo
junge kranke frau ersetzen und jedes
lied ausnutzen und dass sie seit sie
muss sich entscheiden zwischen wäre die
krankheit besiegen
oder sterben des
islams
prozent vor allem magersucht betroffenen
sind übrigens frauen für fünf bis zehn
prozent an der die psychische krankheit
tödlich im gegensatz zu der andere hat
der janet therapie kurve eins zusammen
in die klinik zu mittag hast du denn mal
kontakt mit coaches
er fährt schon mal mit so einem thema
das aber sobald entgangene schicken wir
vor tischdecke oder so kann ich denn
eigentlich gehört oder gesehen alles
machen also ich bin aber gerne immer
vorsichtig sie werden mich
was hast du denn er hofft aber sollte
kontakt gesucht
das verbindlich so macht sich nur für
mich sondern immer dünner für aber
anders und der hort haut auf ich wollte
mit der janet edle psychotherapeutin
über die abhängigkeit und der
mechanismus vorzeitige chats und coaches
retten seien sehr fester mit der person
zusammen wo der kontakt zu ihr oder zur
not serie fischer selbst war problematik
vorhanden dass marica oder interessiert
sich immer für mich da geht mir zu
enteignen dann bin ich wichtig und dass
das einfach ist und natürlich dass man
dann also kontakt gut und glaubten
wirklich so dass die pflege in der
bedürfnisse ich möchte noch verzehren
person gemacht werde gesehen werden
möchte mit der weiteren kontakt haben
und richtig bezirk der nichts gefährdet
dass man dann eine sache macht man
eigentlich nicht mache auch sieht das
mensch im leben gelernt hat das motto
auf gramm zersetze dass man darauf nein
sagen und dass das schadensrisiko dafür
halt einfach zu machen ohne groß zu
überlegen mit über zügig mit wir haben
uns hier mache ich bin nicht so wichtig
die andere sind wichtiger so sind ja
wirklich sehr
individuell über zügig über sich selber
überwald relevant immer das den macht
oder nicht das gefühl dass man in der
fachwelt reise wo sie sind genug weiß
über pro ana und ihre coaches also was
ist schwierig ist dass wir immer wieder
neue wendungen der zürcher mit in der
soziale gedanke man sowie pizza lüge
dass man immer wieder stand ist also ich
glaube noch wisse einiges aber immer
wissen mit längst nicht alles darauf
grundfutter scharf erzähler durch
patienten nicht alles jeanette wird in
das board der klinik rennverlauf aber
unklar ob sie wieder ganz gesund wird
oder ob es wieder rückfall wird die
gemeinde sucht
das schwierig zu sagen
ich glaube einfach dass sie ein
irgendwie ein falsche realität
vorgaukeln und
mutter und mit dem hat einfach mehr
gearbeitet und minden hat wie irgendwie
lernen muss
die decke wo sie deute klinik geöffnet
hat sollte die heidi vorsatz erinnere
aber
was sache gut machen kann und muss nicht
perfekt sie sind einfach nur
funktioniert oder hat aber das ist aber
sache machen da wo jetzt einfach sachen
schön sind somit verringern
jan hat angst die nachricht also wenn
ich nur ein paar komiker und ich mich
mit der decke der krieg groß also
zwischen selber gemacht sich alles um
mehr gemacht
stolz auf sie dass ich abnehmen sondern
auf das man stolz
in der schweiz ist es so dass es
momentan keine rechtliche grundlage geht
zum planergruppe netzsperre der bund
unternimmt nummer dann bis gar keine
online plattformen wenn die gegen das
gesetz verstoßen und vor strafrechtlich
relevant sind zudem könne zum beispiel
pornografie oder gewaltdarstellungen und
dem thema coaches gesetz einfach
essverhalten kürze fall unter cyber
grooming laufen und das gezielte albanel
vor sexuellen kontakt zu erwachsenen mit
minderjährigen übers internet ich bis
heute ihre schweiz kann einige
strafbestand es sind nur einzelne
handlung wie zum beispiel nötigung oder
sexuelle belästigung belangt werden und
das musste mal aus elektro und zum
schluss würde mich interessieren ob ihr
online schon mal ein kontakt ich gange
sind wo ich geschadet hat wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr mit gern der freunde
kommen darf erzählen